and he said that you told him i drowned
my first husband in a swimming pool so
what
you told him you poisoned your second
one didn't you well from her comic
timing
sit down mom i'm doing the talking i'm
not sitting down
put your backside down there on that
barrel also help me
to her matriarchal strength dane barbara
windsor's korea spanned
decades and crossed genres born barbara
and deex
she changed her surname to windsor in
1953
and made her west end debut aged just
15.
after a small role in the bells of saint
trinions barbara windsor was nominated
for the best british actress bafta
for sparrows can't sing in 1964
but it was her appearances in nine of
the 31 carry-on films
that made the actress a household name
with one of her most famous scenes and
carry on camping
in a certain exercise class
and in and fling
[Music]
it was in 1994 that she joined
eastenders
cast as the landlady of the queen vic
peggy mitchell
yelling what would become an iconic
catchphrase
now you get out of my pub
she quit the soap in 2009 saying she
wanted to spend more time with her
family
but returned for cameo roles playing
peggy for the last time in 2016.
steve mcfadden who plays her son phil
mitchell is said to be devastated
fellow eastenders star patsy palmer said
on instagram
we shared such magical times together
and i'll cherish
everyone the actress was married for
nearly 20 years
to form a nightclub owner and convicted
criminal
ronnie knight and during their marriage
she had a well-publicized affair with
fellow carry-on star
sid james dane barbara also had a close
connection with the craig twins
dating both reggie cray and the twins
brother charles
in 2014 she was diagnosed with
alzheimer's disease
and made the news public in 2018.
together with her husband of 20 years
scott mitchell she campaigned to raise
awareness of the disease
the actress was widely credited with
having lifted the stigma around the
condition
delivering a letter signed by 100 000
people to boris johnson
demanding better care for dementia
sufferers and
cheekily asking the prime minister at
the end of their chat
can i have a kiss she was awarded a dame
hood for her services to entertainment
and charity in 2016.
dame barbara's husband scott was by her
side as she passed away
peacefully on thursday night in a london
care home
he called her his precious bar saying
she lived her final weeks
typical of how she lived her life full
of humor
drama and a fighting spirit until the
end